good afternoon everybody i'm councilman
cedric career and i want to welcome you
all to a very very very special day
as we officially break ground on the
historic west side legacy park
i'm the ward 5 councilman for this area
and it's my honor to be your host today
thank you all for coming out i'm so
excited to be here today on the site of
what will be a beautiful new park
next year at this time the historic west
side
is a very special place in las vegas a
place that i've called home my entire
life
and it has a legacy which this new park
will share as you know i grew up in the
west side
in ward 5 and i have been ingrained with
the stories of our community
we share history on the west side that
legacy park will help preserve
ensuring that future generations know
the leaders that came
before us all it would be a place of
reverence
that brings forth emotion and chronicles
the struggles
and triumphs of our community
i very much look forward to this park
becoming a cherished part of our
community
it will feature an interpretive walking
trail a visual timeline of the west side
artwork places to sit and contemplate
and a playground for children to laugh
and play
i want to thank core construction for
being a contractor on this project
i also want to thank lga architecture
and lage
design for the work in putting together
a vision
that will soon become a reality
i also want to give a very very special
thank you to jackie brantley ramon savoy
and clay t white who serve tyler
tirelessly as our selection committee
for this park
i also need to thank my colleague my
friend
my mentor someone that i truly cherish
and that is commissioner lawrence weekly
this project is a partnership between
the city of las vegas and clark county
and commissioner weekly has been a huge
part of moving this park forward
it was actually his vision and a phone
call that we
that he made to me about a park
that he uh he had seen
back in his alma mater at grambling
state university and that park honored
the legacy builders in that community we
have taken it
to a whole other level this park is
going to be absolutely positively
outstanding
not only is it beautiful it's going to
be a tremendous memorial
for all those trailblazers that came
before us and i can't
begin to think commissioner weekly
for having this idea and for us taking
it
and running with it and once you see
what we have you're going to be very
very very very happy
so i'd like to invite my friend to the
podium to say a few words
commissioner
[Applause]
thank you so very much good afternoon
everyone it's my hope and my prayer that
everyone's staying safe and healthy and
that
we're doing all we can do to get through
this pandemic together
to my dear friend and my colleague and
a young man that i have so much respect
for ward 5 city councilman cedric career
you know i'm so excited to partner with
him on
what some look at it as the historic
west side legacy park
i look at it through my lenses as a
historical playground
you know i look at this park and i can
only imagine
all the rich and pure history that have
come through this neighborhood
you know las vegas is known for
imploding a whole lot of things
and not preserving a lot of our history
well that's one of the things that the
councilmen and i decided to do
we wanted to preserve some of the
history and remember
many of the trailblazers who came this
way
when they didn't have many places to go
this was all they had
and so for those naysayers out there who
say well this is a business park
you know we need to put more economic
development in here i 100
agree with that but i also believe that
this is a place
that many of these business owners will
be able to come and walk
through the grounds here and look at the
men and women who made it possible
so that we could stand on the shoulders
that we're standing on here today
i'm so forever grateful you know i
traveled back to grambling state
university and when i got an opportunity
to see legacy park there
i reached out to the mayor and i said
how awesome
this is and at the time my daughter was
still a student there i see
mr gene collins who is here his
granddaughter is a current student
at that university what an awesome
what an awesome legacy that they have
for the councilman and i
to have been so fortunate to be natives
here of las vegas
and then to attend an hbcu and
understand the importance of
no matter how high you get always
remember from whence you've come from
that's the meaning of why we're standing
here today and so to all the partners
who helped make this possible there are
some men and women behind the scenes
who have kept this wheel turning miss
laura
mr harry of course we have miss allie
who is here
mr will and just all just all of the
architects and the designers and of
course this young man who you'll hear
from momentarily
what a great visionary i don't
understand councilman why this young
lady here is not standing up here with
us also because she has been
can i come on i don't want to outstep my
boundaries because this is a city party
but you know how the county do
we always like to run everything right
come on up here christy garnish you know
i love you i thank you for all of our
rich and pure history together
thank you for doing what you're doing
but councilman career you
and the new ward 5 i'm sorry the new
district d county commissioner are going
to move this park forward
it's going to be awesome and i can't
wait until i have an opportunity to
drive down
martin luther king adjacent to lake mead
and mount moriah
to see the new historic west side legacy
park
thank you all so very much god bless you
all happy holidays and stay safe
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you commissioner and thank you for
your years of service on the county
commission
and as a city councilman i know one day
that we will see his name emblazoned
within this historic west side legacy
park because
there are not too many people who have
done much more for this community than
what you have done for us community
and i say that from the heart and as a
recipient of all the work that you have
done
thank you um you know i also want to
thank greg weitzel who is our director
of perks
and our team back at the city you know
so many people
get engaged in doing something like this
jorge cervantes who is now our city
manager
and tom perego and so many other
dr lisa morris hibbler kathy thomas
gibson
you know the list is long and especially
my ward 5 staff and team
because none of this comes without a lot
of planning and sacrifice
on our side and then on the county side
i don't know as many of the names on the
county side but i tell you
they were right there with us in
planning and giving suggestions and
telling us to stop and telling us to go
and
they are absolutely fantastic so uh
thank you to them yolanda adams who's
the county manager
we appreciate them for you know
supporting this project
adams is a gospel singer yolanda king
yolanda king
you know what it's funny yolanda king
i'm sure i'm not the first person that
have done that
yes miss yolanda king thank you
commissioner once again the commission
is correcting me
this park will feature large beautiful
trees and public art with service focal
points
and i'm very excited that a young man uh
is
part of this community uh in and is
there's there's so much synergy with
this young man
that uh it is a pleasure and honor his
uncle happens to be here who was great
who is uh
reverend mccurdy who billy mccurdy who
is our park commissioner for ward 5.
his cousin has just won the seat
for the to replace commissioner weekly
william mccurdy and just raised
right down the street here and so chase
mccurdy
is a part of this legacy park team he is
consulting on the history that will be
weaved into this park and will be
responsible for art installations
at the park and chase i want to invite
you up
to say a couple words tell us a little
bit more about what you're willing that
you're working on
and how you're going to incorporate your
art into this beautiful park
chase mccurdy
um all right
uh hello everyone um first off this is
uh
truly an honor to be a part of this
project um
as excuse me councilman mentioned
i'm a proud very proud third generation
native of this
particular area of las vegas with the
first of my
ancestors coming here in 1939.
as the artist and consultant on this
project
i hope to honor the legacy of those who
came before us
with a monumental sculpture called the
living black
pillars with the the desire to
make a monument of sorts a new monument
for
this part of our city the historic west
side of las vegas which is extremely
important not only to myself
but those who came before those who are
still here and those who are going to
come after
as well as the original art sculpture
that's going to be in the park
there is also the addition of a
historical narrative
that will weave throughout the park so
that visitors
both from the community and outside of
the community have an opportunity
to learn more about not only the people
that came before
but some of the events places
and those individuals and groups who
made the historic west side what it is
and allowed that spirit to to live
through
an amazing time into our future as well
so with that
thank you to core construction thank you
to lga
lage design uh for your attention and
desire to
really execute at a high level and
respect this this project
and the the people that it's here to to
honor and serve
and i look forward to stepping foot in
the park once it's complete
thank you
thank you chase um i want to go a little
bit off script and invite someone up
uh who has been instrumental in this
project she has worked tirelessly in
in you can tell the creativity and the
passion
that has gone into this park right you
know you can see some things that are
being built and it's called a
sort of four box and it looks the same
and everything kind of
you know uh comes together but this is a
personalized project
that has been built from the ground up
from the dirt
up and every single detail
has been scrutinized to the extent
and she is a part of lga and i want to
bring her up and miss alexa please come
say a couple of words i know you didn't
plan it but we we need you to say
something
okay so like i told you i didn't plan to
speak
about anything but um i'm honored to be
here representing lga architecture
and the core construction design build
team
it's a great project important project
and we will
we spend the time to put the design and
the and the care in to make
make sure that it's a project that the
community will love and cherish for the
years to come
i'm very honored to work with chase and
through chase working with the community
members to really make it special
for the west side community thank you
very much
[Applause]
he said great that was that was easy uh
thank you uh lga lage
and core you know corey has been a
partner of ours for a long time as well
as
other developers are actually working
and building on our
homeless courtyard down on four master
so we thank you for that work that you
guys are doing as well you guys are true
partner to the city of las vegas and we
appreciate you
once again legacy park has been a
community-led project
and will continue to be moving forward
we have had public meetings
to discuss all aspects of the park and
we look forward to making additional
announcements in 2021
about some of the other features in
history that would be included
in the park i would be remiss if i
didn't offer thanks to all those from
the west side
whose shoulders we stand on today
i have truly had some wonderful examples
to follow and i am thrilled that we will
now have a special place
that we can honor all those who came
before us you know in my home many of
the people who were going to go in this
park
would have meetings at my house with my
parents and
with my father to discuss next steps for
the community
and and uh i remember being a little kid
and seeing these individuals coming
together i had no clue what they were
talking about
but uh it seemed pretty serious and they
were pretty
uh you know focused on trying to make
our community better
um and so i want to thank them and i
want to thank you all for joining us
today
and i would like to invite the speakers
as well as any representatives from core
construction lga architecture
lage design to join us as we officially
break ground
on the historic west side legacy park
thank you all